muy buenas tardes pues esa es la
incógnita hasta ahora porque no se sabe
cómo fue ni a través de contacto de qué
persona el presidente de manuel ma con
contra ese contagio con la vida de 19
esa es una de las preguntas por ahora
que se están haciendo no hay más
detalles acerca de cómo está el estado
de salud del mandatario en el escueto
el escueto comunicación que dio el
elíseo esta mañana solamente decía que
había tenido algunos síntomas a leves y
que se le había hecho esa prueba que
finalmente había dado positivo como
usted bien lo dice pues son sus
contactos más cercanos los que han
estado que han comenzado a estar
aislados sobre preventivamente que ya
sea por ejemplo pedro sánchez o antonio
costa de la primera ministro de portugal
pero también el presidente del consejo
europeo ya o michel con quien él estuvo
también he reunido el día lunes porque
la agenda del presidente marco ha estado
bastante llena desde desde finales de la
semana pasada esta semana ha estado no
solamente con ron castex el primer
ministro sino también se reunió con
varios miembros de la convención
ciudadana por el clima pero hasta ahora
ninguno de estos contactos cercanos del
presidente marco han dado positivo todos
están en aislamiento preventivo habrá
que esperar una semana para saber si hay
algún tipo hay algún otro contagio
alrededor del presidente marco